speak I'll then invite you at the
appropriate time please note that the
YouTube live stream live stream sound
recording is dependent on the correct
use of microphones therefore can I ask
that when invited to speak you remember
to turn on your microphone and then turn
it off when finished please reference a
page or paragraph number when referring
to the agenda papers and keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible
item three's apologies for absence and I
understand we have no apologies which is
fortunate because there's only three of
us
um item four disclosure disclosure of
interest to disclose the existence and
nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests other registerable interests
and non Regis registrable interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard
to paragraph nine and appendix B of the
code of conduct for members members
you're also reminded that you are
required to disclose any such interest
as soon as you become aware should the
need arise through the meeting looking
to see if members
now um in the interest of openness and
transparency I have a I'm a personal
license holder
okay so um item five on the agenda which
is the application for a premises
license uh Mrs Salisbury at the miter to
the street Wycombe Bishops this is a
gender item five found on pages 5 to 36
in your pack
uh I refer everyone present to the aid
Memoir found on page two of the agenda
pack which details the procedure we're
going to follow for this meeting firstly
I need to ask that everyone has read the
officers report and appendices and
evidence submitted which was circulated
prior to this meeting should anyone have
any late documentation in sport of the
representation or the application this
may be introduced only with the consent
of all parties
um have you read everything I'm sure you
have from our discussions so
um members if you wish to speak just
let me know please and then I will come
to you
um
now other members or other people
persons present at the meeting could you
introduce yourself Mr Salisbury you can
go first
foreign
everybody yeah my name's Mark Salisbury
I'm
um here today just to say a few words if
anyone wants to fire any questions at me
okay thank you Mr Silver and we have is
that Mr Gorn if you could take a seat
you can stay seated there um Mr gorm for
the interests of
the microphone yeah moving all your your
stuff
and uh good morning my name's Stephen
Gorn I'm an objector but I have some
Support also for the applicant so okay
we'll come to you in due course Mr
Gordon thank you very much indeed uh Mr
winter the licensing officer could you
just now give us an outline of the
application please
thank you chair good morning all
the purpose of this report is to
consider an application for a new
premises license under Section 17 of the
licensing act 2003
have a regard to representations
received and the requirement to promote
the full licensing objectives
her recommendations are that the
licensing subcommitted determines the
application for a premises license taken
into consideration the options that are
available as detailed in paragraph 4.1
below
the complete application for the above
premises will secede on the 16th of
January 2023 including the plans as part
of the licensing process a complete copy
of the application was sent out to all
responsible authorities for consultation
the application has been properly made
in accordance with the licensing act
2003 and all proceedings procedures
correctly followed the completed
application form is attached as appendix
a please refer to the appendix for
details of the proposed license of
allowances should you need to do so
the applicant has provided conditions
consistent with the operating schedule
intended to provide the four licensing
objectives which are included as part of
this application form
the application was correctly advertised
in a locally circulated newspaper and on
the premises within the time scale
allocated under legislation and on
Malden District council's website
the closing date for consultations was
midnight on the 12th of February 2023 we
received a total of 22 representations
for this application 13 of these were in
support of the application as attached
as appendix b and nine were opposed to
the application as attached appendix C
members are asked to note that as this
report is published publicly personal
details have been redacted from some
documents however the licensing
Authority and the applicant have
received complete copies of all
documents
there were no representations made by
the responsible authorities
conditions imposed by Essex police were
agreed by the applicant should the
license be granted and these are
attached as appendix d
the nominated designated premises
supervisor the dps's mark Salisbury who
has obtained a personal license with
this Council that is held since January
2006.
the land at the proposed license
premises primarily a residential area of
houses with a couple of commercial shops
next to the premises this is attached as
appendix e which details the location
around the premises
members are advised that they have the
following options when determining this
application they can grant the
application on the terms and conditions
applied for or Grant the application on
the terms and conditions applied for
modified to such an extent as considered
appropriate to promote the licensing
objectives or they can refuse the
application in whole or in part
members are reminded that the applicant
and or any person make a representation
in relation to this matter May appeal
the decision of the council to the
magistrates court within 21 days of the
notification given by the licensing
committee thank you chair that concludes
my report
thank you very much Mr winter
Mr Salisbury now's your chance to um
give us some outline about the
application please
right um we uh Mrs salisbury's tabrams
has been operating
um for the last 10 years approximately
in Moulton High Street
and what we're trying to do is basically
do uh exactly the same in Wickham
Bishops we hold occasional events
outside in the summer months which which
is generally one evening
a month approximately typed in
ballpark about six evenings during the
course of a year
um days range from all manner of
different things which we've done in the
highest Malden High Street uh site from
Cinema evenings to live music events
with by local artists
um black probably pretty much it is it
for our Live Events we operate from 8 30
currently at the moment until 4 P.M and
we've been serving alcohol without any
trouble at all over the lot since the
Mrs Salisbury Tea Room that opened and
prior to that
um
another site in Rayleigh also The Secret
Garden as well in Malden we had a drinks
license there as well so that pretty
much sums it up really he's
predominantly a tea rooms we're not
looking to do
anything
the same as the previous tenants that
was in the miter where their DJ evenings
Etc
that's not for us we're just sticking to
our existing business model which seems
to work
um my first question would be the
premises license belonged to a lady
called Claire made who's who owns the
premises but somehow the license was
surrendered
buy the previous tenant that was in
there Mr Buckley and you know I don't
know whether that was in error but
um yeah that's pretty much it really
okay thank you very much indeed um I'll
take it you haven't got any witnesses
that you wish to call in in no no
Witnesses and there are no responsible
authorities
apart from the
the police conditions which we've just
looked at chair I do have a response to
that question okay I may
um in relation to the previous license
holder
um I myself have spoken directly with
Claire
um at the time um some time ago she did
correctly transfer the license into the
previous license holders name or
business name and that gives them the
right to surrender it should they choose
to at any point which they did and this
was questioned by Claire I think at the
time she perhaps was misunderstood as to
what the actual transfer of the premises
license actually meant and she was more
Guided by the the the license holder
rather than coming directly to the
licensing department for advice
but I have checked those records and it
was correctly transferred to the old
license holder and they did surrender
the license I thought I'd just answer
that question thank you for clearing
that up yeah thank you
does does that effectively mean it's
been trading without a license for since
it opened but
um since the new business has opened uh
they're licensed to sell alcohol if they
haven't been selling alcohol then
there's no unlawful activities
um but they can open as a business
providing the not selling alcohol
they I think by from what Mr Salisbury
said you have been serving alcohol nice
oh you haven't no we haven't I'm selling
alcohol okay so there's been no
licensable activities not yet since you
ain't since you okay that's fine that's
that's cleared that up thank you very
much indeed uh Mr Gorn it's your turn
now sir
um you have technically two minutes
I think will be very lenient with Mr
Gordon I'm sure you know we don't want
to put you on a timer and
you know it's uh State your case anyway
Mr Gore thank you I have practice so
I'll see if it does take me two minutes
first of all thank me uh thanks for
allowing me to speak this morning my
name is Stephen Gore and I'm a retired
managing director our home in Wickham
Bishops is about 350 meters from from
the miter premises when I submitted my
uh words to the to the council I also
stated that I was very pleased and we
are pleased that Mrs Salisbury has
reopened the miter so I sit here this
morning
um both objecting to some elements but
very supportive of the fact that the
miter has been reopened and hasn't
having visited the miter under the new
management under the newer tenants
um it definitely is a good addition to
the Village
um it may be a commercial business and
you're right though it's located close
to two other commercial properties but
the vast majority of uh houses around it
the vast majority of Residential
Properties
um I'm making the representation today
based on the prevention of public
nuisance and to a lesser degree the
prevention of crime and disorder which
are the two objectives that I I
recognize from what you've set out the
protection of the public nuisance
centers on the application private
provision of live and recorded music
during business hours of 8 30 to 4 but
more specifically outside of the
building between 4 and 11.
um
recorded or live music within the
premises I I don't think anybody has a
problem with because the level of noise
or level of noise generated has to be
such that you have a duty of care with
employees so I don't think anybody
thinks of the inside of the buildings
being a problem the biggest issue in the
prevention of nuisance is related to the
noise generated by recorded live music
both Amplified and Amplified in the
outside garden area past experience of
All Families nearby is that the music
played with or without amplification
until 11 o'clock had a major impact on
them especially if taking place on the
school night you know Sunday through
Thursday whilst acknowledging the new
proprietor is likely to operate on a
higher standard than the prior tenant
it's clear music played on the outside
the miter will travel you know the noise
does it's easy to request that the
committee refuses application in whole
however in recognizing Mrs Sudbury is
adding positively to the Village
amenities I believe it's too drastic
the business study wishes to hold
pop-ups on occasion on an occasional
basic basis which would involve the
outside after normal hours I.E 1600
hours in the day-to-day business they
say to they plan to really have live
music also the applicant states that in
the summer months and we heard that from
Mr Salisbury earlier is when they plan
to have events outside and are likely to
have events once per month and that's
all good stuff
as I see from the application though the
license is a the application for a
license is for every day I.E 365 days of
the year
which is at odds with the explanation of
what to come the business wants to do
outside
given the applicant stay a position in
the objections submitted I would
respectfully request the committee Grant
the application as submitted but
modifies so as to limit live or
recording music Amplified or unalplified
outside the premises to one Friday or
Saturday per month between four sixteen
hundred hours and 2300 I firmly believe
this will allow the Mrs salary business
to meet its stated goals and will
prevent or avoid a public nuisance thank
you for your time
foreign
thank you um I'm sure it was around
about two minutes but that was uh that
was excellent um
members um have you any questions for
the applicant Mr Salisbury I'd just like
to ask you if if you were to accept that
proposal just if you were would that or
would that not be acceptable to you and
if not why would that not be
um listening to his comments a lot of it
makes perfect sense
um we live in the local community we
live in Wickham Bishops ourselves we're
looking to embrace the village and the
residents so everything the same makes
perfect sense I know
uh they had quite a bit of trouble with
the previous tenants which is completely
understandable to be skeptical of our
proposal
um we'd be happy to have that modified
to say Friday Saturday Sunday which
gives us a little bit of wiggle room
for inclement weather
um
yeah I think that would pretty much yeah
we could we could work with that if they
could extend it to say Friday evening
so would that be Friday and Saturday
yeah Friday Friday and Saturday evening
would be acceptable yeah not Sunday
evening
so two nights a week yeah a couple of
the weekend it's a couple of nights to
be fair
um what's right here is one evening a
month
but in all the time that we've been
there
we've we've probably done three to four
a year maximum with all the will in the
world we want to do more but generally
speaking our day-to-day business is so
busy that we're exhausted by the time it
it gets to doing the events it all seems
like a good idea at the time
but the the ones that we do when we can
get the enthusiasm they are really
really good evenings one thing I would
say from obviously this has been quite
sensitive in the modern High Street as
well uh all our live news is always
finished at 10 o'clock on the nose and
then uh the site has been you know with
carriages for for 11 p.m so
think that pretty much covers no please
do yeah no yeah thank you and I I think
you know just just listening to this it
seems to me that the residents
themselves and the village actually are
in favor of this business I think it's
100 Place yeah and it's very important
for us as a small business that we
Embrace their concerns as well exactly
so the main concern and I fully
understand that from residents is loud
music going throughout the week so we
are talking about the weekends some
weekends we're not talking every weekend
are we we're talking absolutely not it's
difficult to do that
yeah so I think well thanks for help
answer this question
thank you Mr chairman with all these
applications you have on ours thing and
you apply for what you can use but you
might not necessarily use them exactly
and you've explained what you want to do
but you have to apply for more than what
you need more than what we actually need
yes that's fine thank you okay
okay
um I don't have any questions
um from Mr Salisbury
um
so you can now make a closing statement
if you wish I think you probably I think
I've achieved that much covered it
um hopefully that you people have
actually been to our tea rooms and seen
how we operate
um we employ approximately 50 to 60
people full-timers in the district
um
yeah I've got nothing else to say really
hopefully that's covered everything
um
no other comments no
okay thank you very much indeed we've
heard that we need to hear Mr Salisbury
thank you very much and from you Mr
Gordon oh
yes yeah
thank you thank you sir I'm sorry I
don't know your name but I just want to
put that is that I mean you've heard the
sort of discussion that's gone on is
that something that would be acceptable
I I think most people would accept you
know once twice once a month as they've
laid out it's a Friday or a Saturday is
is very reasonable you know especially
when you're trying to encourage the
business which I think the majority of
the people in working Bishops don't do
they they do want it to succeed so I I'd
be happy with as as I proposed a
restriction to Friday or Saturday per
month
because that's you know what Mr
Salisbury who's actually asked for in
his uh application so yes long way of
answering your questions yes thank you
thank you
okay uh so um I think we've concluded
all we need to do
um so this meeting now will close thank
you very much indeed for your attendance
um Mr Salsbury we will make the decision
after the immediately after this meeting
and then you will be advised in writing
within five working days
um and if you don't agree you obviously
have the appeal too
uh the magistrates Court should you wish
to do so
um as I said thank you very much for
your attendance both
thank you
of the meeting well it's the meeting
closes you can close the stream yes it
uh
uh 10.50 it closes thank you